the search continues this weekend for a
missing two-year-old boy
amari nicholson was last seen wednesday
near paradise and twain
madison kimbrough has the details about
today's community search
and joins us live from metro
headquarters with the details madison
yes this afternoon nevada child seekers
and numerous volunteers were searching
for answers
what happened to two-year-old amari
nicholson
i do believe someone knows where he at i
just want him safe i just want him found
and we i just want answers two-year-old
amari nicholson went missing wednesday
after being left with his mother's
boyfriend
at emerald suites off of paradise road
the boyfriend says a woman who claimed
to be the boy's aunt picked him up
and that's the last time he was seen
we're just knocking on doors and seeing
if any of the residents
have seen the little boy nevada child
seekers organized a community search
party to help find the toddler
a lot of these people don't know that
he's even missing yet so it's working
we're going to be here all night and
we're hoping that somebody knows
something and they can call the police
and let them know
we came out today we made flyers we just
want to make sure that he's safe
and we want to find find them we are
distributing them through the emerald
suites
hotel anyone that we see out there we're
talking to amari's father who lives in
reno is distraught over the fact
there has not been an amber alert issued
in the state of nevada
he wants more people to know what's
going on you never know someone could
have seen him someone could have heard
something
i'm in i'm in reno hearing about it and
i'm walking up to people
in vegas and they still haven't heard
that he's missing it's been three days
now
now as of now metro is actively
investigating omaree's disappearance and
the hayes family is offering
a 30 thousand dollar reward for his safe
return
of course if you know anything you were
urged to call crime stoppers we have
that number up on our screen
if you know anything you are urged to
call like i said you can remain
anonymous
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now